hey what's up everybody it is monday
february 14
2022. it's valentine's day are you
feeling the love i hope you woke up to
chocolates and little candies with
meaningless slogans on them and i hope
you're going out to dinner with someone
you love i hope you're surrounded by
roses and all that good stuff and
whether you are or aren't you're here
with me
and i love you as much as
someone on this side of the camera could
love someone watching me you know what i
mean like i have very warm feelings for
you people you guys
seem to like me when i meet you at the
store you say nice things sometimes
people say they love me and i always
find that a bit much it's like you know
doing the best i can here but you know
it's cool
but i do love you guys to a to a certain
extent it would be the definition of
love that we'd have to whittle down
that's for another show
but i am very excited to be here on this
monday morning we got a big show for you
we're doing another one of these
narrative shows this seems to be the
trend that we're moving uh in over here
on the reuben report where we're doing
sort of half hour shows with a real
through line from top to bottom
as i've mentioned to kind of show you
where we were where we're going how we
got there and maybe how we could get out
of some of this nonsense what we're
mostly focusing on today
is just the abject lunacy that was on
display at the super bowl yesterday the
endless hypocrisy and nonsense with
celebrities unmasked as they mass
children and we're going to mix in a
whole bunch of politicians and all that
stuff and i will have to
put a lot of money we got an official
jar you know i've been talking about
this escape cali fund and at the end of
the year every time i mention california
gratuitously on this show because it's a
horrible horrible place and i don't want
to bludgeon you
by talking about california now that
i've fled but every time i mention
california i will put another five
dollar bill into this jar we've got a
whole bunch of them today okay because
i'm going to be talking about california
a bunch because the super bowl was in
los angeles and what we're going to do
is at the end of the year we're going to
take all the money that has been put in
here and we're going to give it to
somebody no strings attached to move
from california i'd like you to move to
florida
that would be my goal but if you're if
you go to texas you go to tennessee
south dakota whatever arizona be just
fine i'd prefer it to be someone in
florida we will this will be for someone
in the locals community so if you want a
chance and i'll throw in a couple extra
thousand bucks too at the end of the
year because i just feel so strongly
about this that that we must destroy
california and we must save the free
state of florida and some of these other
free states so we're gonna be throwing a
lot of cash in today okay people that's
what we're doing here on the reuben
report oh and i didn't mention it but if
you're watching this you might be
watching on rumble and i appreciate it
you might be watching on youtube and you
might be watching on blaze tv that's
just fantastic do me a favor subscribe
and all that good stuff and before we
get to any of that people i want to talk
to you about the stack you know if the
last two years have taught us anything
it's that you must take control of your
own health ain't it the truth it's clear
that you can't simply rely on the
government or big pharma to protect you
and your family that's where a z-stack
comes in z-stack is a specially
formulated immune boosting supplement
that includes zinc chrysaridin vitamin c
and vitamin d formulated by dr vlad
zelenko the world-renowned doctor that
president trump credited with his early
successful treatment protocol and his
decision to take hcq zstack has been
scientifically formulated is kosher and
gmp certified and it's produced right
here in the good old us of a by taking z
stack daily you're super charging your
immune system z-stack is formulated to
help combat any and all variants as well
as the flu so i encourage you to take it
now to stay ahead of any potential
future variants by preparing your immune
system by ordering c stack you'll become
part of the z family and receive
exclusive updates from dr zalenko on his
on this pandemic go to zstacklife.com
dave today and enter the promo code dave
to get a small discount off your first
order that
zstacklife.com
dave promo code dave and now back to me
okay trust me
this is a jam-packed
show if hypocrisy
and nonsense and lunacy and psychosis
are the types of things that could knock
you out of your chair or off your couch
then i want you to buckle in i want you
to sit real tight okay i'm i'm back in
my chair today because it's just
endless with these people
and we have to figure out how to deal
with them going forward so yesterday of
course was the super bowl it was the los
angeles rams versus the cincinnati
bengals i did not watch one minute of
the nfl this year i was never a huge
football fan but i've always somewhat
enjoyed it certainly always watched the
super bowl probably since i'm 10 years
old um didn't watch any it's
everything's just become so politicized
colin kaepernick black lives matter all
the stuff they've just ruined everything
you guys know all that uh but the super
bowl was in los angeles so not only was
it a los angeles team the rams but it
was also in los angeles that's pretty
rare that that happens and they did ask
for people or require
people to wear masks we've got the
official quote from the la times nfl
officials joined with local leaders to
reiterate that masks will be required
for fans at the super bowl in inglewood
okay so masks were required at the super
bowl in englewood do i have to repeat
myself okay now
people started showing up and let's
remember of course los angeles is still
in some version of lockdown tons of
restaurants are still closed people
aren't going to work the crime all the
stuff that you guys all know about
they've got the kids in masks still to
go to supermarkets you gotta wear masks
i mean thank god i left that horrible
place and here's some cash to prove it
put some cash in the jar right now i
would do this throughout the show
but they go to the super bowl to people
and they're required to wear masks and
then there was this really fantastic
video that they show on the official
broadcast of celebrities at the game and
are they wearing masks
we're in hollywood who do we got here we
got jay-z
[Music]
matt damon
at least iran is here
[Music]
lebron
[Music]
emmett smith
there you go there's my kind of
celebrity yeah now we're talking of
course there's an all-time celebrity row
here tonight for super bowl 56 andy
garcia
chris tucker taking it all in get those
pictures basketball royalty in the house
lebron james and of course frozen magic
johnson actress as well charlize theron
is in the house
mark wahlberg making a call making sure
his peeps are here
looking cool as ever
and matt damon
look at all
of those los angeles area celebrities
people who are better than you they're
rich they have power they're elite they
are served by people who are always
wearing masks but they don't have to
wear masks even though it was required
even though i have no doubt that
virtually all of those people who are
leftists uh have had no problem with
mandates and keeping kids uh you know
masked up and everything else there's
ben affleck can we go back to ben
affleck over there for just a sec can we
go back to ben because ben as you
remember you may remember ben affleck i
dedicated don't burn this book to ben
affleck because he's such a psychotic
hysterical leftist that he had that
crazy moment with bill maher and sam
harris on his show years ago that was
one of my wake ups to how insane the
left has become so he's with j.lo over
there who else was in there we got the
rock i think he was there yeah there's
the rock this is the same rock person
rock man who uh you know about a week
ago defended joe rogan then got a little
pushback
so he rescinded his defense of joe rogan
only to have uh a tweet where he called
someone a [ __ ] exposed so they're just
great people these people who else we
got one more there was the that's uh
what's his name who's that guy ryan
reynolds i think he was uh he was green
lantern or something there's that guy
and he was deadpool thank you and
there's lebron
mr chyna himself so it never ends with
these people of course then there was
ellen degeneres and i thought this was a
good one uh because alan posts this
selfie here ellen is enjoying the super
bowl without a mask yet she still
requires her audience to wear a mask
hypocrite that's from the libs of tick
tock uh twitter which is really
fantastic one of the few good things on
twitter but really look at that really
really look at that there's ellen
degeneres
leftist hero
progressive
lesbian the whole shebang
and now look what she does to her own
audience when they're at her show i've
been in that studio okay uh it's a big
studio a lot of room a lot of air the
stage is very very far from the audience
and she keeps them all masked up and
there's all the stuff that you know the
stories that have broken about her in
the last year where she doesn't let
employees look her in the eye and like a
whole bunch of weird stuff these people
but i i know
and i want to be clear about this i
don't think they're calling out their
hypocrisy is going to do anything i
really don't so we'll get to what we can
do to them uh in just a minute um but i
think it's important that we at least
really see it like really see it and
feel it because they are still
ramping up not just keeping kids in
masks in los angeles california in
places like new york they're actually
ramping it up to some degree uh now here
of course is the mayor of los angeles
this is my former mayor eric garcetti i
hate this man eric this is for you five
dollars to get someone to flee los
angeles and move to
florida uh so there he is he's standing
there he's wearing a ram's outfit he's
talking to me but his mouth appears to
be open now one of the key things uh
that he has told us when he's talking to
people and they want to take pictures
with him is that he holds his breath
that's one of the things he says he
holds his breath when he takes pictures
so that he cannot get or spread covet
i'm not making this up i think you
probably saw this last week but here you
go
i wore my mask the entire game and when
people ask for a photograph i hold my
breath and i put it here and people
could see that there's a zero percent
chance of infection from
evil like there's nothing else you can
call this than evil there's a zero
percent chance of infection if i hold my
breath while taking a selfie please show
me the science on that you prick like
please
and not it's just absurd like it's
absurd at every level because you then
you probably just sucked in a whole
bunch of germs you're a liar you're a
fraud you people need to be dealt with
again we'll get to that in just a moment
but if you think that the hypocrisy in
watching all these celebrities not
follow the edicts that they're all for
and then of course you know all the
employees that work there the people
that are working for minimum wage that
are serving them the beer and the drinks
and they're all sitting in there you
know in their boots in those boxes that
you know cost hundreds of thousands of
dollars and all that good stuff
they don't mind that but they also like
to have kids masks masked when they're
around kids even at the super bowl
here's video from the la youth orchestra
and as you'll see the kids have to wear
masks the adults not so much
[Music]
just paint in a picture of hypocrisy
here because the mask stuff is actually
getting worse in los angeles right now
as it relates to kids because for these
past two years you've been allowed to
wear a cloth mask now there are many
reasons that you shouldn't have had to
do that at all and certainly after the
two weeks to flatten the curve thing we
all should have reevaluated we all made
mistakes along the way um okay so be it
but for two years people have been
wearing cloth masks and now of course
all the experts are coming out and
saying cloth masks don't work you touch
your face more you know the germs can
get up and then they down in it and
sideways in in
as you know fauci was telling friends
that masks don't work in the first place
so don't worry about it when they're on
vacation while he was literally telling
us to double mask i mean these people
have lied about everything at every
level
endlessly non-stop this entire time but
now they're even upping the mask
situation uh back in january the end of
the month so this is really about two
and a half weeks ago we've got some info
from abc news students in los angeles
public schools must wear a non-cloth
mask with a nose wire at all times
including during sports the district
announced in a letter to families this
weekend these people are criminals and
hypocrites and again at the end i will
get to what we should do with them
meaning that the cloth mask that they
told us was doing something for the last
two years it does jack [ __ ] and they've
decided oh now that we know or we're
going to admit that it does jack [ __ ]
we're actually going to have them all in
n95s with the metal on the nose we know
that it's affecting children's mouths so
speech is now delayed they can't see the
teachers the way they use their mouths
so for young kids this is absolutely
horrific but democrats just keep pushing
more and more we've got a tweet here
from kyle becker who's an actual
journalist over something that happened
this weekend breaking
221 house democrats blocked
consideration of the unmask our kids act
which was h.r 6619 so basically
republicans were trying to get something
passed to get the kids out of masks and
221 democrats criminals they're
criminals they're criminals and child
abusers that's what they are sorry uh
they blocked it um and it just
continues so new york governor kathy
hoechel you know this woman this is the
woman that zero people i don't mean that
as a white supremacist sign zero
zero people voted for this lunatic okay
she's the one that replaced andrew cuomo
when he stepped down and you may
remember my show when i came back on the
grid on september 1st of this past year
after a month off that's when andrew
cuomo went down was in august and uh
adam carolla was the guest host on the
show and adam corolla tells me you know
cuomo's out and before he told me
who was stepping in to take take charge
of new york i said whoever it is they're
going to be worse i have no doubt that
they're going to be worse we should have
clipped that and grabbed it
because of course i was right because
that's what happens with all of these
people well now kathy hoechel has
extended the statewide mass mandate for
two year and up kids in school okay two
years and up she wants these kids in
masks well
i
can't believe we have here's kathy just
a couple days ago look at her smiling
god she's the c word c word i'm sorry
i'm sorry i know i can't say it because
can i will i will we get demonetized if
i just say no i won't say the c word but
if i say the c word
i'm not going to say the four letter
word but i'm saying the c word we're
screwed we're screwed it's worth it
whatever it's worth it she's the c word
what else can we say about these people
so there she is masked kids yeah who
cares about the kids even though there's
no chance these kids are gonna die of
covid uh and the adults they're all just
fine they're all just fine uh but
there's more from her right we've got
more from the super bowl or is there
another room oh no we've got another
image oh here's the super bowl one yeah
this is great so this is her yesterday
in buffalo so she's masking kids and
here she is indoors in buffalo with that
shit-eating grin i despise these people
i don't know who that dude is he's
probably fine but like i just i
absolutely hate these people and then do
we have the other image of ho chill from
a couple days ago hoe cold holster look
at her she wants to be a celebrity more
than anything else with the masked
reporter and she stands there wanting to
be a celebrity and a star on a red
carpet and uh
you know can i also vomit in this thing
i should probably and i'm sorry that i'm
not going to save someone from new york
i'm giving all this money for someone to
escape uh california but like you know
i'll help new york people escape here
i'm putting in 10 bucks right there for
this this is just i've just had it with
these people so if you're in the reuben
report community again just start
letting us know if you're thinking about
getting out of cali i'm going to give
somebody a couple thousand bucks at
least maybe we'll do more i will figure
it maybe i'll crowd crowdfund it you
know a million bucks will you take a
million bucks and get the hell out of
there um
if you don't think that what these
freaks and liars and hypocrites are
doing
is evil well now we've got some video
this is from benny johnson on twitter my
buddy benny johnson who's been on the
show
some video out of las vegas and here's
what happened at a grade school when the
teacher told the children that they no
longer have to wear masks
starting tomorrow we don't have to wear
masks anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
you see what they've done what they have
done to innocent children these people
are child abusers that's what they are
so kathy holchel she's a is it hotel or
hokule i don't care she's she's just
kathy c word that's what i'm gonna call
her for now on kathy's i'm gonna call
her kathy c for now on put that in the
notes okay going forward kathy c over
here okay
this woman so she's expanding the mask
situation on the kids okay and at the
same time she realized the adult she
realizes that the adults have had it so
now we've got video of her and she's
actually rescinding some of the stuff
related to businesses because this is
all very very confusing
we had a
mask or vax requirement for businesses
it was an emergency temporary measure
put in place literally two months ago
and at this time we say that is the
right decision to lift this mandate
for indoor businesses and let counties
cities and businesses to make their own
decisions on what they want to do with
respect to mask or the vaccination
requirement given the declining cases
given declining hospitalizations that is
why we feel comfortable
to lift this in effect tomorrow
ah so she's lifting it in effect
tomorrow which i think tomorrow means
today actually uh she's gonna leave it
up to counties and businesses and people
to make choices for themselves which is
exactly what all of us crazy right
wingers have been demanding this entire
time but now they'll get cred oh my god
you see there's a liberal who's not a
complete [ __ ] lunatic oh my god and
everyone will go you see she's such a
good person kathy c word she's so great
she's letting people have some choice
which is exactly what the rest of us
demanded this entire time well you know
what kathy c word i'm not letting you
get away with it because now
there is a new study that has come out
that has shown that lockdowns
did jack
poop okay we've got some info here from
the washington times lockdowns in the
u.s and europe had little or no impact
in reducing debts from covid19 according
to a new analysis by researchers at john
hopkins university the lockdowns during
the early phase of the pandemic in 2020
reduced covid 19 mortality by about 0.2
percent said the broad review of
multiple scientific studies we find no
evidence that lockdowns school closures
border closures and limiting gatherings
have had a noticeable effect on covid19
mortality the researchers wrote but the
research paper said lockdowns did have
devastating effects on the economy and
contributed to numerous social ills they
have contributed to reducing economic
activity raising unemployment reducing
schooling causing political unrest
contributing to domestic violence and
undermining liberal democracy the report
said such a standard benefit cost
calculation leads to a strong conclusion
lockdowns should be rejected out of hand
as a pandemic policy instrument the
paper concluded okay
lockdowns didn't work
they didn't work they were made up from
the beginning okay it was all made up
none of this had anything to do with
science all of the masks all of the
nonsense everything that they've done
and then the second part of that is more
interesting it's like not only did it
not do anything related to covet to stop
people from getting coveted stop the
mortality rates and everything else it
actually damaged everything everything
about the world that we now know right
all the stuff that is worse now right
economically
uh socially all of it it is worse now
because of this so then we thought all
right well that was from the washington
post could we get some other headlines
like maybe the washington post maybe
they're not that bad maybe they're kind
of coming around well how about this for
a little juxtaposition here are two
washington post headlines one of them a
couple months back when they were going
after ron desantis it's an opinion piece
i will grant them that but they've
really blurred the lines between opinion
and editor and uh actual fact checking
so opinion florida's new anti-masking
law denies us key tools to protect our
schools from future coveted surges well
i just read you a study that shows
that's complete nonsense but that's what
they were telling you over the
washington post a couple months back
because it would make florida look bad
and then of course just from a few days
ago washington post mass mandates didn't
make much of a difference anyway
do you see how they've made people
completely insane if you have tried to
use any sense of logic and reason
throughout this thing if you have tried
to not become a complete psychopath and
paranoid lunatic during all of this it's
a miracle and that's why i say if you're
roughly sane right now and i suspect if
you're watching this if you're ballpark
sane you're not just like a complete
paranoid nut bag you haven't lost your
mind you don't believe in completely
different things the entire system
hasn't broke you then i commend you and
i offer you five dollars in the jar to
move someone from crazy california
to free florida now what's beautiful
about all this and there is a silver
lining
okay and i am going to get to what we
have to do to these people at the end
but there is a silver lining there are
thousands and thousands millions of
people worldwide that are standing up to
this nonsense right now
the the draconian lockdowns the way they
have abused power that that western
democracies have become completely
illiberal has woken up the masses and
they make it very hard for us to see
right because cnn won't cover it and new
york times won't cover it or at least
they won't cover it in an honest way but
we've been talking about this canadian
trucker convoy for the last two weeks
where thousands and thousands
if not at this point millions of
canadians are standing up and saying no
more this [ __ ] trudeau we want to go
back to our lives you don't own us and
trudeau is just absolutely worse we'll
get to him in a second but the convoys
have been going all throughout canada
it's just been beautiful trudeau of
course said it was because these people
are transphobes which would mean that a
whole bunch of people got together and
because of their irrational fear of uh
of trans people they started protesting
throughout canada but it's spreading
okay it's spreading throughout the world
here is australia
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
beautiful like absolutely beautiful and
guess what it's not going to be a super
spreader event and those people chose to
go and they love their country that's
what they're actually applauding for
right there absolutely beautiful despite
the insanity of what's going on over in
australia but it's spreading throughout
the world here's paris france
[Music]
[Music]
i have no doubt that those people are
all over the political map some of them
are more conservative some of them are
more liberal these are people who just
want to live freely so we've got canada
we've got australia we've got france and
this just in the last two or three hours
from jerusalem israel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you think that's because those crazy
jews have an irrational fear of trans
people or maybe it's because their own
government has forced them to be
injected four times and 87 boosters and
everything else uh now before
we get to the next portion of all of
this and then to my conclusion about
what we're going to do with these people
uh just a bit more of what's going on in
canada right now
[Applause]
[Applause]
do you guys see the through line here at
these protests they have the flags of
their nations because these people
realize that the people
are the rightful inheritors of the
nations not the politicians so those are
people with canadian flags chanting
freedom what you saw a moment ago was
was good decent australians with
australian flags talking about how much
they love their country and we've shown
you all the videos how instead of
burning down buildings and looting and
everything else which the mainstream
media told us was okay all over the
world during black lives matter and all
the rest of the nonsense of the last two
years
do you think that maybe that was because
they really wanted to just get rid of
trump and we haven't actually solved
racism but they don't need their foot
soldiers out there anymore so it's all
stopped in the last year because they've
got biden as the president you think
maybe there's something there
crazy i know um
these people are good people who love
their country and just want to live
freely and they're not bigots and
racists and everything else and i will
continue to stand with them and now
i thought this would be an interesting
thing to show so bill maher and you guys
know i've been somewhat critical of bill
maher because he's he's just late to the
party and it's fine and when you're late
to the party
i think those of us that have been here
first that have gotten most of this
stuff right we want to be gracious to
the people that get here but we also
want to get them to the end of the road
well bill maher on his show on real time
this past friday uh really went off on
justin trudeau and i would just preface
this by saying bill maher a liberal and
justin trudeau the head of the liberal
party
in canada
take a look he started to read what he
he said
this is a couple of weeks ago he was or
maybe this is september but he was
talking about people who are not
vaccinated
he said they don't believe in science
they're often misogynistic often racist
no they're not that was not part of him
at all right he said but they take up
space
and with that we have to make a choice
in terms of a leader as a country do we
tolerate these people it's like tolerate
dude now you do sound like him that's
that that way and recently he talked
about them holding holding unacceptable
views
i'm surprised to hear that trudeau said
those things
you didn't see the black face i mean
no i'm kidding i'm not i'm not
i mean that was not a good look for him
but i i mean
come on i mean that's i think what gets
under people's skin
all right putting aside bill maher for
just a moment there's marianne
williamson on there marion williamson
who has had i've had on the show
uh who did my show and then the second
the cameras went off basically told me
that she actually was a libertarian and
that she had never got as much hate from
the right as she was getting from the
left and she called it a cult
not only is that true i assure you that
that's true but she was also i think it
was on eric bowling's show on newsmax
once where they left the mic on after if
i'm not mistaken and she said the exact
same thing to him but so she sits there
shocked she's got her duck face you know
she does a
that thing that women do
like this
i'm shocked i can't believe they trudeau
would say that sort of i can't believe
it but she's a good liberal too why are
you shocked this is what you people have
brought upon us so first again i want to
give bill maher total credit here and
watching him get there has been great
and again bill you gotta and i know the
producers are watching you gotta get to
the end of the road you gotta tell
people to stop voting for democrats it's
as simple as that otherwise you guys
just usher in all of the nonsense and
then you try to basically destroy
republicans and conservatives and then
two years later you just repeat what
they're saying and then everybody
applauds you for it this game cannot be
played anymore like maybe there was a
time where that game could be played
right and i get it like the real-time
show is sort of an airlock for what's
allowed in in mainstream culture or
something like that but this cannot be
played anymore you get it bill so it's
time you can't just say uh the liberals
the liberals your royal idiot i'm a good
liberal no maybe there's something wrong
maybe there's some a bigger problem okay
i don't want to get lost on that
um but it's good to see it
by and large it is good to see that this
is happening
so before we get to the uh the final
segment today which is just a hum dinger
that you're gonna love uh a couple
locals comments uh sweetwater
says a sincere thank you to every
citizen of the world who is fighting
tyranny yes i thank all of you good
people and thank yourselves and thank
each other uh pat says next time the
super bowl should be held in america
that would be good that's a good one
that's a good one i see you did there uh
chuck bob says i have a friend in
california who sent me a mask for
christmas i didn't have the heart to
tell him we haven't worn masks in my
state for months and months oh my god
can you if i got a mask for christmas
like that would be it i don't lose
friends over politics all right at least
not it's a one-way street for me so i've
lost friends over politics their choice
i don't get rid of friends but if
someone sent me a mask that's it
wrapping it up anyway
the the theme of today oh and i've got
some more money here i want to give to
the uh to the fun let's just put some
more money in the fund for the good
people
hate you eric garcetti kathy hoechel
oh i'm sorry kathy c word that's for you
there you go
if you think the people have not had it
and if you think that enough of us don't
get it yet well then this is just the
most beautiful thing you're ever going
to see
the mayor of boston her name is michelle
wu she is a democrat she is a
progressive she is a liar and a
hypocrite and an anti-science buffoon
just like the rest of them she hates
children and i would argue that
basically she's a child abuser at this
point that's what these people are
okay well cat uh michelle wu i almost
called her kathy c word but same
difference
uh she did an instagram live
to talk about her policies and uh well
the people weren't having it
oh since she's unable to join
okay
in the meantime i will
try to just fill this
by answering any questions anyone has
um
see a lot of
friends who uh
have different oh happy new year yes
year of the tiger very very cute tiger
emoji
[Music]
it goes on
and on and on at one point she has so
little to say she just looks at the
camera and says i love snow
okay
these people are horrible the masses and
by the way you think maybe this is why
they want to censor us you think maybe
this is why algorithmic tricks
and making sure that people don't see
certain comments and youtube took away
the down vote thing you think all these
things are connected because it's the
people who are standing up against the
elite that woman is just a horrible
person i like
i don't get any great joy talking about
these people this way like it's sort of
funny in a way kathy c word but like in
another way these people are child
abusers they have no respect for the
laws of the united states they don't
care about the constitution they don't
care about just your innate ability to
live freely as you see fit so as i've
hinted at several times what do we do
with these people what do we do with
these people i was thinking about it all
weekend like i actually stopped watching
the super bowl after the first quarter
last night i just could not take it i
could not take it i was just like the
hypocrisy here it's off the charts like
i don't care enough about the game and
the commercials all suck the commercials
by the way are all member berries you
know member berries from south park
where it's basically like people just
like need to like so oh my god i
remember that thing from 1986 and i love
old references but like all the
commercials are just old songs and old
references and everything else of a time
that was better than the [ __ ] that
these people have ushered in now like
there's nothing new we need some new
stuff
but let's put that aside for a second
what do we do
with these people
now i don't think we're the side of
lists right like the other side likes
lists remember after the election when
when trump was out and aoc and all the
democrats were talking about the lists
we're going to have to have lists of
people that supported trump so we know
who to go after right who they can put
in the gulag and everything else it's
like we don't like lists i i don't like
lists of political enemies and that sort
of thing
but
we have to think honestly if we're ever
going to get out of this let's say cobit
is sort of wrapping up right now like
you can see it it's too obvious for
everyone right now all the stuff that i
just showed you like it's too obvious
the abuse of children versus the way the
elites live like it's it's the cat is
out of the bag
so if we're and also because of the
midterms you can see the democrats are
opening things up that's why hokel kathy
c word that's why she is now rescinding
the the mandates and things because she
knows the democrats are about to get
trounced in the election as they should
no matter how badly they should get beat
they get beat it should be probably 10
times worse
but as the narrative shifts we cannot
forget what these people did
go back to the study that i just
referenced from washington post from
john hopkins university some of the
things that they have done to us
actually can we pull that part up again
connor can we pull up some of the text
on that or i'll just i'll go off here uh
some of what they've done in terms of
the depression and everything else
phoenix you can go down just a little
bit what they've done not only did they
find no evidence that lockdowns at
schools that that it did anything but
get me to the part of the things that
they did notice that it did a little bit
further down
they had devastating effects on the
economy contributed to numerous social
ills they have contributed to reducing
economic activity raising unemployment
reducing schooling causing political
unrest contributing to domestic violence
and undermining liberal democracy okay
but you guys don't even need a study
to understand that you know what it's
done in your own life the the division
it's caused amongst friends and family
the anger it's caused amongst your
co-citizens and everything else uh all
the stuff related to kids and that
they're still putting kids in masks and
all of these things so what do we do
with these people and i i guess i don't
have an exact answer
i do think to some degree we have to
jail some of these people like these
people should be put on trial we need
some
we need some mechanism to get out of
this we can't just even if we're really
going to open up right now
which of course we should open up fully
and i live in florida so i'm i'm doing
just fine over here okay
um
but if the country and the world is to
open up again
like should we just move on and and not
do anything about the people that did
this to all of us that that ruined the
world that was pretty good and maybe
maybe not enough of us fought for that
world for long enough maybe we didn't
realize how good we have it and had it i
guess had it better than have it
what do we do and i think the only way
we can actually put a pin in it and say
this was a moment that we must remember
is that some of these people must be put
on trial these people that abused our
laws and abused our children
and and ruined so many people's lives
and the drug use and all the stuff all
the stuff you know it so i would love to
continue this conversation i will
continue it in
reubenreport.locals.com we'll get the
community talking about in there and
i'll read some comments tomorrow and i
think we really have to do think about
it we really do have to think about it
as a as a as a free society
you know when they give you your freedom
back it's like well who took the freedom
and why'd they take it and are there
repercussions for that that's what we
have to figure out but i think some of
these people they have to go down i hate
to do it i don't like the idea of gulags
i don't like the idea of political
prisoners but they have done something
extraordinarily evil here and there has
to be a price to pay
that's how i'm kicking off monday with
jailing my political opponents you see
what you've done i hope you're happy
here's a little more cash for the escape
cali fund there we go it's my last five
dollar bill for today i think i put in
100 bucks today that's all right that's
all right
guys part one of my interview uh with
charlie kirk from turning point usa
will be up on youtube and rumble this
afternoon the full is up on
locals already have a great day
everybody and to kathy c
we'll see you soon